Привіт! Мене звати Ігор Дейнека
і я лікар 25-тої Української антарктичної експедиції
До моменту зарахування до експедиції
я працював лікарем-анестезіологом у місті Рівне
Багатьох членів експедиції хвилює
перехід через протоку Дрейка
Це займає новачків. І я серед них :)
Подивіться якось на You-Tube відео
про цей прекрасний атракціон
Вчора провів семінар про морську хворобу
Здається, трохи заспокоїв
і себе, і таких самих «першачків» :)
Зараз саме той момент, коли потрібно бути поряд
зі своїми колегами, які
зараз декілька тижнів поспіль
не виходять з лікарень і виконують
справді героїчну роботу
попри усі ризики
А ти дотримуєшся правил карантину?